hey how's it going my name is Bell whoa
on this channel we only play quality
games it's all about the best games ever
so I turned to the Japanese market and I
found this wonderful game called
love death for real-time lovers is that
bull Vereen there's a lot of you know
what let's just play it see what it's
like I'm sure it's great it took me
forever to download this game and find
this game and figure out how to run this
game put a lot of effort into this game
so I expect it to be good the hell is
going on
okay so this is me let me charge my
penis Wow let's go baby it it kicks me
in the face stop kicking me woman
save me she's crazy I need to fight back
right fight oh this is what you're GERD
for disrespecting me
it's that that what I what is it's
coming from it's censored why is the
baseball bat
censored oh my god she's sleepwalking
get off me cop Oh what the [ __ ] is
coming down there why is that bra
floating in the air damage you got away
I mean it we should do it live with it
get rag
let's just get right
okay that was love there for great game
like you enjoyed watching maybe I'll
check out the other love deaths they
seem pretty quality gameplay so bottom
line call them don't worry if you know
what I mean thank you for watching just
like back in high school in the teenage
eggs